Hey guys, welcome to- welcome dragons to my- what are you talking- welcome everybody to Dokefield's home.
Did you guys bring any lasagna?
What do you mean a costume?
We've stumbled into a portal to an alternate universe where I am Dokefield.
Hey guys, I've always been a cat.
What are you talking about?
See, look, all you say was that I was born this way.
So I don't know why you're judging me right now.
I've- I've always been a cat.
I've always been an orange tabby.
Do you guys like my happy Halloween?
John?
Who's John, guys?
The only person I know.
What are you guys talking about, dragoons?
There's no John here.
We- we have- look, we have you.
We have this guy.
That's not John.
Oh, you mean dad.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Uh, Odie, no.
That's one of the dragoons.
You don't recognize your own kind?
Don't worry.
Dragoon!
Dragoon, get over here, dragoon.
Get over here.
Run!
I don't know what you're talking about.
Where are you?
Okay.
Yes, um, sorry.
I had, like, some technical difficulties.
I'm so sorry, guys.
I was a little late.
I realized I- I had a little bit of some, uh, technical difficulties going on.
Uh, but, like, you guys can tell why.
Uh, I mean, it was very hard to get this house decorated to fit the theme, you know?
Um, other than that, I've always looked like this.
Uh, I've always, um, I've always looked like this.
I- I don't know what you're talking about.
I mean, it was weird that you came through a green portal.
That- that was a little weird, but other than that, like, everything else was, like, the same.
Oh, you guys- you guys want to meet dad?
You guys want to meet dad?
Dad!
Get over here!
Oh, sorry.
Let me fix you guys real- real quick.
There you-
There's dad right here.
Uh...
Wait, what do you mean disappointed?
I don't understand.
What?
No, that's how he's always like.
Guys.
Dad, I want my lasagna.
I- Dad, where- where is my las- where is my lasagna?
Where is my lasagna, dad?
I just- I just- Wow, Dougfield, you spent how much just to make a shit post on Halloween?
What are you talking about?
This- I've always looked like this.
I- I- I don't know what you guys are talking about.
I've- I've always looked like this, but since I've came back in February, this- this is how I've always looked, and I- I don't know why you guys think that- that anything is different.
This is- this has always been- this has always been what I looked like.
I don't know what to say.
I don't know what to say, Dragoons.
Like, I don't know what else to say, guys.
I've always- it's always been like that.
Anyway, all right.
Anyway, dad.
Dookie Amber.
I'm gonna go back to the room now.
Go make my lasagna.
All right, anyway.
I'll say it, but dad looks low-key white.
What?
That's wrong, dad.
Stop.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, I've always looked this way.
I- I don't know why everybody's freaking out.
I don't think anything's wrong right now.
Anyway, um...
I hope you guys enjoyed the new- I spookified the intro.
Um, I forgot to make a fancy credits page, so I'm gonna write down the credits at the end of the stream.
Uh, but yeah, we had a lot of people.
Um, yeah, we had one person basically, like, uh, well, no.
What am I saying?
This is me.
What am I- what am I saying?
Nobody made this.
No.
No, sorry.
Sorry, impression ruined.
Sorry, it's- it's just so hard.
Okay, it's just getting a little difficult.
Minus one RP.
Oh my god.
All right.
Anyway, so, um, yeah, I can- what are you guys looking at, huh?
Chat, what are you guys- oh, wait.
Chat, you guys are- you guys are a little- phew.
Let me fix you guys real quick.
Yeah, what are you guys looking at, chat?
There's nothing weird going on here.
I- I can't even take myself seriously.
Like, wait.
I mean, look at me.
I mean- I mean, look at me.
Like, what- what do you want me to say?
Okay, sorry.
Hey, guys.
I don't know about you guys, but I feel like...
I don't know why they had Chris Pratt instead of me.
Mondays, am I right?
I- I know.
I- I look- I look very normal.
It's so true.
Mondays, am I right, guys?
Am I right, Dragoons?
Oh my god.
I hate Mondays.
I- In the Dokefield universe, it's already Monday.
Every- almost every day is Monday.
Oh my god.
This is- wait, Dragoon, get out!
Get- get out!
This is my- this- this is- this is my stream.
What are you doing here?
This is my stream.
Um, guys, she's losing it.
What do you mean?
It's adorable Halloween.
Damn.
The only thing different is that, you know, I decorated the place a little different, you know?
Like, instead of we're at the- we're at the- the- I almost said salon.
The saloon.
We're at my place.
This is where I live.
You guys like it?
You guys like- yeah.
You guys like my bed?
You guys like- it's like the newest craze.
It's all- it's all the craze for beds, you know?
Apparently, when you sleep on the floor, it's better for your back and, um, um, and like, it's good for your back and your muscle and stuff.
So yeah, this is where I sleep.
And then look, I carved a pumpkin over there for you guys.
Yeah, it's just a- just adorable.
Just- don't feel the doki breath.
Yeah, it keeps my back straight and everything.
Um, also, you guys like my- you guys like my- you just have no- no, I have a choice.
I have choices.
I own this place.
That's just- that's just like my waiter.
He brings my lasagna and everything.
Like, I- what are you talking about?
What the fuck?
What do you mean, what the fuck is that?
It's me!
Dokefield!
It's always been Dokefield.
Like, what do you mean?
Sorry, Dokefield.
How am I in danger?
I don't understand, guys.
I- hello.
Hello.
All I'm saying is that I feel like you're taking it a little bit, uh, too extreme, um, with your reaction.
Because, like, nothing- nothing is wrong right now.
And, like, I don't understand why everybody is, like, freaking out about, um, the way I look.
It's- I- I feel like I'm being judged at the moment, dragons.
Like, are you guys- are you guys judging me?
Are you- are you guys judging me, chat?
Are you guys judging me?
That's not- that's not becoming of you.
Um, that's- that's a little rude.
That's all I'm saying.
It's a- it's a little rude right there.
Yes.
We can cast light.
We can keep Garfield.
What do you mean Garfield?
It's Dokefield.
Copyright.
It's- it's barely- barely legal version.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, um, I've been- okay, all right, all right.
RP done.
RP.
Let me- let me go to the- let me go here.
All right, all right.
RP done.
Okay, um, all right, let me explain this.
Let me- let me- let me explain what the fuck is going on.
So, um, yes.
I- I may or may not have done all of this just so I could be my hero.
Just so I can be my oshi.
It was, um, it took like- I actually planned this a while ago.
It's a little sad, but like, you know, I was like- I was like, it's Halloween.
Like, when will I ever have this opportunity again, you know?
Like, it's- it's-
So I was like, oh my god.
It's- it's Halloween.
So like, you know, normally I was like, all right, what do I do for Halloween?
And I was like, oh my god.
I could be my hero.
Yeah, I could- I could- I could- yes, yes, yes, chat.
I- I spent a lot just so I could shitpost on Halloween.
And was it worth it?
Yes, it was worth it.
It was indeed worth it, chat.
It was indeed so worth it.
Anyway.
Also, um, you guys can also show up here.
Give me a sec.
Where is it?
Oh, there you guys are.
Here you are.
Look at that.
You're over here, too.
That's all.
That's all that- That's- that's all that matters.
You guys can come back again, too.
Watch.
Look, see?
Look at you guys.
You need to talk about your spending.
What do you mean?
This is money well spent.
I- I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
How dare you judge me?
How- how dare- wait, let me see.
How- How dare you judge me?
How could you guys?
I can't believe you guys would judge me like that.
Like, I- I don't understand.
I don't- look, now I'm not happy anymore.
I don't understand why you would judge me like this.
I feel like the money I spent on today was so worth it because like, I mean, look.
When- when can I ever have a chance to have- to be TocField when- This is- this is where your super chat goes to.
This is where your super chat goes to.
Yes, instead of- instead of buying, um, naturally, um, um, instead of buying furniture or plates or like, you know, or like a Roomba or like unpacking or, you know, or like basic necessities or cutlery too.
I spent my money on TocField and I think- I think it was worth it.
I think-
I think it was honestly one of the smartest investments I ever made in my career.
Um, also I need you guys to know that like I've actually been planning this for like even before- even before I came back, I've always wanted to do this, but I was never like a more, you know, a more like parody wise, you know, not straight up like fuck that's- that's- that's TocField right there,
but-
Like I've actually been planning this for like at least a year, but I was never able to do it like logistically wise like, you know, red tape and everything even if it was like more of a parody, but like now!
Now!
Who's gonna stop me?
Who's gonna stop me now?
No one!
No one can stop me now!
This is what happens when you give me too much freedom, guys.
This is what happens.
This is my mind on freedom juice.
This is what goes in my mind.
You know, other people they're like, yeah!
You know, yeah, so anyway, um, um, it was really cute that um, uh, by the way that animation in the beginning that was done like within- the animation itself was done within like three days.
Um, it was like a last minute idea I had.
I like contacted one of the animators that I had like, you know, one of the animators that I know and I was like, uh, like a week ago, I think a week and a half ago and I was like, can you do this?
And they were like, I'm on vacation.
I'm on vacation, but- but I could do it on the 28th.
So then they actually- they actually like did it, um, they actually animated this from the 28th and then the 3D modelers made the models within a week and oh my god, I need to show you guys.
Okay, they're so cute.
Let me show you guys the concepts, the- the costumes that they um, the costumes that they like, uh, made for it.
Oh my god.
I love looking at myself like I can't-
I'm sorry.
Okay, anyway.
Anyway, um, this is so good.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting distracted there.
I need to- I need to focus up.
Sorry.
Um, as I was saying, let me- let me grab the concept.
All right, real quick for you guys.
So, um, I don't know if you guys saw but uh, um, I- uh, I was giving like costume designs to give you guys and to be like, all right, like what kind of costumes do I- do I- do I want to give you guys and the one of them that I was so happy about was the fact that um,
they gave you- they gave the chonky goons, um, they gave the chonky goons, um, a sexy cat costume and I was like, oh my god, that's perfect.
That's actually so good.
Oh, let me- let me- let me- let me grab it.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting distracted looking at myself.
I'm so sorry.
I can't-
I can't believe it.
I can't believe this is my head when I'm- this is my head when I'm fucking shit- Okay, okay, let me uh, let me- Sorry, I'm getting distracted.
I'm just- I don't know.
I just look so beautiful.
I don't know.
I mean, look at me.
I'm like- I mean, I mean, come on.
I mean, come on.
Come on guys.
Look, I know you're- look, come on.
I see you guys looking.
I see you guys looking over there.
I love that like- I love the fact that people sort of instantly knew um, what the surprise was because like they saw the- they saw the whiskers.
Reality can be whatever I want.
Zekro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But you guys literally saw the thumbnail and like these guys saw the whiskers and were like, oh my god.
No.
No, it can't.
It can't be.
There's no way.
Does she actually do it?
There's no way she actually did it.
Oh, but joke's on you.
I did.
That's right, I have too much money now.
I have too much money.
Okay, um Um, all right.
Sorry.
I actually need to show you guys.
So here are like the concept art.
So this is by- this was done by Nim.
Um, I'll show like the twitter profile like- oh, I'll show the twitter profiles later.
But this is by Nim, the concept art.
So you can see there was like several concepts.
So there was- obviously I chose the sexy cat because I thought I was like fit.
And then I gave you guys the mummy and then there's the halloween basket too.
So these were like the choices that you could have been.
What you could have been in the halloween animation.
But yeah, like I said had the idea like very last minute regarding the animation because I was like, how the fuck do I transition to Garfield?
I was just like, what do I do?
How do I- how do I transition to this?
Like I can't just instantly, you know
I can't just instantly bring you guys there.
It's like the hard cut after the intro.
So I was like, oh my god We're gonna teleport you to an alternate universe Where instead of jokey brood, it's jokey cat.
I was like, oh man, I'll be- I was like, that'll be a little awkward.
Um, oh yeah, but here's the concept art for the others too.
This is what you guys could have been.
So um, um, I love that the longoon could have been So the choices was like a pyramid head or the tomato I thought the ghost was really cute So I was like just because I wanted to make it like more More like, you know, halloween-esque.
So I thought the ghost was really cute.
So I went with that.
Um Uh, but yeah, let me wait.
Is there anything else?
Is there anything else like okay, so this whole thing my My garfield suit.
Sorry my joke field suit.
Um, this was made by uh by the way The 3d models were made were re-outfitted by nim and salted fish and the animator was ramen You might know might have recognized ramen for the animating.
Uh Um croaky and frog bird animation that we did, uh that was animated by that was Animated by them in the beginning the beginning segment.
So yeah, the animation 3d animation was done by ramen again Also, so this whole shit post This entire shit post was made by one guy
It was it was made it was made By one guy and uh And um Let me link you guys so I saw his stuff For a long time a while ago and I was like, holy shit this is like It's so cool.
So his name is he is also a vtuber his name is This is goblin and his whole Yes, it's by jim davis himself, um, I contacted jim davis and I was like he jim davis have you do you know what vtubers are Do you know, um, what is a virtual youtuber
So Um so Um, so my entire thing my entire skin suit.
Sorry.
Can I do I call it my entire?
Uh jokefield suit was done by one guy including all of this like the the backgrounds and everything and um This is the guy so I saw his stuff.
I was like, holy shit That is so creative.
This would be perfect for garfield
Um Um And I was like, yeah, so I was like, oh my god.
That's so you know, they do, you know, they are Oh my god, you know, like holy shit.
They they are They're crazy talented like insanely Talented like i'm me It's not a fursuit it's literally me It's literally me it's not It's not a fursuit guys.
I oh I swear to god Oh, don't make me don't make me angry.
Oh, i'm looking at you right now
Do not sorry wrong hat do not make wait wrong hat do not make me angry I swear to god Oh
I'm just i'm cosplaying that's different That's different.
I'm just cosplaying guys.
Like I don't know what you're talking about.
This is just this is literally cosplay
Even further beyond Um um but yeah, like huge shout out also the chat was uh coded by uh I always commission the same people to do stuff because it's just It's easier because like i'm like I know you got you do well, you could do stuff well, so I always go back to the same people to um,
usually so the chat was done by uh, uh sigma I'm, sorry What?
Sigma cw so that was done by I was like, oh my god uh, I really wanted to like have it look like a garfield comic so like even like you know your chat and um the chat and everything and like the super chats and alerts looks like Look like basically like sound effects and stuff.
Um And uh, yeah, like I don't know I did pick put a lot of thought into it.
I just just really happy This was like one of the things I requested and it was this I that was like a last minute.
I was like, oh my god.
I need this I can't help every time I like look at myself laugh.
It's like a Feedback.
It's like a looping feedback and it makes me wanna Laugh It makes me wanna laugh even more I just see it and I was like, oh my god.
I have been like a looping feedback.
I'm like watching myself laugh and I make just It's so it's so dumb it's so good, but it's so dumb at the same time Anyway Um Anyway, also this I I requested this too Um, and you guys already see you guys already saw yourself so many times.
I was like who's gonna be od I was like, why am I asking that?
Of course, it's gonna be you This is my glimpse into the mind of a comedic genius.
Thank you for the super chat.
No, this is just somebody with Who just has too much money and Sometimes just does stuff to shitpost like that I just i'm just this is what happens when you give a shit poster too much money.
Like this is where your super chat goes into
What a normal I there was not enough time guys there was there was not enough time So instead of instead of buying the basic, this is why I don't have plates guys.
This is clearly much more important um There's clearly much more important chat like I mean look at me though
All right, I think you guys had enough of uh, I want to go back to my own room guys All right.
I'm going back to my own room Um, I need a fucking fixed chat.
I'm too lazy.
No.
No, i'm too lazy.
I'll do that another time if i'll ever If If doug field ever comes back i'll do that and i'll fix chat another time I don't guys I don't even know if this is gonna be used more than once.
I don't I don't even know it's just it was just for halloween.
I literally just wanted to do this for halloween Um, yeah, you like my You like my um, I I have an excuse to be lazy now though.
I do um Guys, I have an excuse to be lazy.
I'm literally him.
I'm i'm literally him guys.
I don't
God this is my life now This is my life just because Just because i'm a doug field Uh, um, yeah, i'm just role playing i'm not actually that lazy guys.
I'm I'm, just role playing everybody Thank god.
We're on Youtube.
Oh you guys like my hips.
Whoa.
Yes like that.
Well, let me shake.
Let me shake my hips The one time I show hips
Um, but yeah, so I can I can point to the sky and be like i'm actually and then I can also wave to you guys I can be like anyway Um, here's my 30 page lecture of why lasagna is great and then I could be like and here's chat And i'll be like, I don't know and I can also be like whoa Oh,
I could do like whoa and then look at you guys too and Look right look down.
Where am I looking at?
Oh my toes
And then I could be like I hate mondays
Um, and then Um, and this is one of my favorite you guys seen it so many times already, but it's still one of my favorite My favorite, uh things which is putting you guys here like that's you That's you There you go.
Goodbye There you go And there you go.
Finally a cat vtuber.
Hey, you guys want me to be a cat girl, right?
It's not what it means Wait, isn't that what cat girls are?
Yeah Isn't that what cat girls are I mean, this is basically a monkey paw situation you're like I wish jokey was a cat girl, and i'm the next best thing
I'd say this is even better than being a cat girl because i'm a little cat Is this what the weaves are into Now I mean it's basically better better than being cat girl.
I'm literally him i'm my hero Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What if we're od does that mean you put no I would never Guys, you guys have no proof Yeah, you guys literally have no proof that that happens.
Look how happy you guys are.
Look see Look You guys are so happy.
Look see look at you guys.
There you are.
You're so happy Oh, bye
Yes, look look look like you're having a good time, um So yeah Happy halloween.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So I literally sorry I was late coming back because I literally just got back from my dance lessons Um, so for the by the way phantom thieves concert buy tickets.
I don't know my mods around but okay My mod can link the ticket.
I don't Wait, I don't think I don't even know if my mod can link the the tickets Check out the phantom thief concert ticket.
Uh Um Cats don't dance.
I'll teach you.
Okay.
Anyway, that is why i'm doing dance lessons.
That's the whole entire point That's why I am doing dance lessons right now Uh I'm sorry, john tj.
We meet john's dad.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you Thank you pulled your guys dragoons.
Can we have cat girl doki doki bird?
We have cat girl doki at home Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Anyway, so I literally just got back from my dance lessons like uh, 30 minutes before the stream I didn't finish setting my stuff up because I was so busy today Um accidentally sort of like Dashed myself to the dance teacher.
So if she's watching right and she's like I subscribe to you I I subscribe to your youtube channel and I was like, oh fuck
So if you're watching please don't say anything please don't do not mention about dirkfield, please I don't i'm Look I could do this online But like I don't know if you could if you if you approach me to talk to me about my halloween stream I don't know how to feel about it.
That's I I don't I don't know how to feel about it.
I
I can hide behind the screen, but then when you talked about it to me in real life then like oh my god It's too real It's just it's just it's just too real at that point.
Anyway, um so yeah, uh Uh, so yeah, they were like wow.
Wow.
Do you are you like are you what do you do?
Like what is it for because you know, like how do I explain?
like how
How do I explain what I do What what like i'm like, you know, it's a concert like they're like, oh, what's this concert?
What's this concert for?
I was like Okay
So, um Um, so yeah Accidentally.
Yeah.
I was like I had to I straight up was like, oh I have to go back I have to go home now.
I have a I have to do my I have to do my halloween stream and I hope she's not She's watching this.
I'm, so sorry.
This is This is who you're teaching This is This is this is your student right now
Oh my god
Anyway, um Doki for this next move.
You're gonna want to shake your hips like I feel like Thank you for the super chat Deadpool.
Thank you.
Thank you I hope she's proud of me.
I really I really hope she's proud of me.
I am And what I do Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
You ever heard of Vtubers and this is the first thing she sees live.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Look I am I'm, just so happy to be my oh my gosh guys remember by the way guys You know, you know, like, you know, my nendoroid is coming out guys, you know garfield nendoroid is also coming out too So like, you know what to do, you know Jim davis,
please.
I'm your biggest fan.
Please.
Um garfield, please.
Let me please.
Let me do one like a Any type of collaboration I you don't even have to pay me i'll do it for exposure i'll legitimately do this
I'll do it for exposure He's my hero, he's he's my please he's my hero I swear to god I i've I really I just want to be close to my oh, she that's all
Like you don't even I swear you don't even need to pay me.
I just want my name next to my oh, she that's all I want What's up, man?
Money No, this is my audition tape, this is my audition tape look if they're willing to hire chris pratt to fucking voice garfield I mean like Their standards are already low enough.
Like I I think I could make it in I think I I think I think it's possible.
I feel like your standards are already low enough if if that passes not gonna lie Chris pratt, please i'll even pay you.
Please.
I swear.
I'll i'll even pay you jim davis If you let me do something with garfield, I well I I would even say i'm better than chris pratt not gonna lie.
I i'll even say that um Okay, to be fair chris chris pratt in his prime was a lot better like he's not in his prime anymore But like i'm basically like chris pratt now Um, which is like not in his prime, but like, you know, you know, like i'm clearly a bigger fan I know the entire lore of garfield.
I actually own physical books of garfield.
So like please jim, please I don't I don't know if like you even do anything anymore.
I'm you don't even I okay I shouldn't say that I was gonna say you don't even draw your own comics anymore But like that's because you know, you already you you've outsourced, you know, you're you're you're a delegator.
You're like a leader Mr. Davis you're You're a leader so you don't need to do your own comics anymore.
You're a delegator and that's That's a that's that's so cool He's a success exactly he is a successful businessman and because of that like, um, I feel like we could be so well connected and like we could do
And And like Like look at look at what I was able what I can do by just shit posting now imagine if you unleash my potential if you
Oh my god get my hands down
Anyway dare I ask what you've done with john and od what do you mean?
Oh, you guys didn't see you guys Oh, oh, he didn't see him.
He didn't see od.
There's no od here.
There's only you See, there's no od here There's only you
Od doesn't exist in this universe.
Uh, there's also okay for those who missed out on dad.
Here he is All right There you are i'll fix the chat later i'm a little lazier i'm i'm lazy right now i'm art play role playing
For those who who missed out on on dad Dad I need I need doki amber doge.
I need I need lasagna You know, how can I have some lasagna I'm truly becoming the character
Um cryptic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Joke field is a jump scare.
I didn't know I should have been afraid of this will haunt my sleep.
What do you mean?
Why would it haunt you?
I am I am literally like Peak vtubing right here.
This is where we've evolved to from anime girls to cat girl.
This is i'm literally a cat girl This is what you've always wanted i've seen people be like wow Well, oh my god, when will she be a cat girl and be like
Wait, wait
She did not like wait, oh my god wait, okay
All right, please don't do it with this it's too late it's too late blame the guy that was late Wait Okay All right.
Um Hello everybody today i'll i'll do a acapella because I don't want to demonetize this I mean Maybe it will get demonetized
Okay, um, all right, all right you guys ready all right There's not gonna be a bgm.
All right
I don't remember the lyrics
But um
There you go, there you go see it fits don't you stop no What do you mean I mean it fits i'm literally a cat singing a cat song like like isn't this what you guys want?
Oh, you guys are nothing will make you happy Go But i'm a cat girl, I don't know what you're talking about I took you stop you're ruining this you're ruining it Good good
There's no fixing her chat, um, but yeah, so um Please check out all the amazing, uh creators that went into doing all this.
Oh, it's neat.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm going to super today about how I feel bad for how much we roasted you lately What What?
What is it?
Huh?
What what is it?
What is it?
What did I do?
What did I do guys What did I do?
I I'll have you know that like This was one of the best investments i've ever made
This was one of the best investments I ever made I don't that's all i'm saying and I feel like I feel like you guys just You guys just don't appreciate it.
I guess just don't appreciate art.
I guess like I mean like What's wrong with this?
I I don't see anything wrong.
I I could have added more honestly.
I I really could have added more stuff to this, uh cat suit but Time was not on our hands I was This is a It's just it's just it's not it's not cursed I think I don't think it's cursed I think it's perfectly normal.
Um Lord corrosive.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you at this point It might be easier to list out what you haven't done.
You know what I want.
I want lasagna.
I want
I Wait, wait, I buy lasagna You know what you know what I want lasagna right now This is how we'll celebrate i'm using the New call system i'm using Lasagna on a paper plate.
That's the dream right there That's the dream right there Don't you dare oh my god guys, this is the goal um Super chat equals lasagna time
So get dragoons paying a swap to this cat suit during normal is that how it works to be fair I had like I I don't even know I don't know what i'll use this again.
There's like zero There's zero fucking I have no idea if i'll ever use do this again, I just thought When when I just thought halloween like like halloween is like the perfect time, you know Oh, well, I can't say that I've paid for this mess lasagna before but here we go Johnny,
let's go Switch into soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Let me add some lasagna.
Oh my god My first lasagna, okay um clip art Oh my god My first lasagna of the day Okay, did I spell lasagna correctly?
Johnny, thank you Thank you for the lasagna guys, don't worry it's so worth it guys It's so guys all i'm saying is that this is a really good investment into the lasagna coin This is a fever dream don't worry guys My my white It's not even Sorry, let me Grab a transparent.
Let's sorry.
I fucked up.
Sorry.
It's not I fucked up.
There we go Thank you.
Thank you for the kind lasagna donation.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god Thank you.
I really appreciate johnny for the very for the first lasagna donation on zekra Thank you for the magenta soup.
I thank you.
Thank you.
This is a fever dream What do you mean now I have two lasagnas now You want plates on oh my god, all right paper plates paper plates clip art Okay.
Sorry.
I mean real.
All right So demanding now you want plates.
Oh my god next you're gonna be like Jokey when would you buy like real forks and i'm like, why would I need a real fork?
I when I can just throw away a wooden fork and then it will decompose And it'd be oh not and then we can recycle it like isn't that better?
Oh my god.
Oh my god faint smile Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you Sure.
Oh my god three lasagnas now.
I need three plates guys.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec guys i'm trying to get more plates guys, there's Oh my god.
There's so many lasagnas I did not.
Oh, no, it's not.
It's not transparent Wait, why isn't this transparent?
Ah everything.
Okay.
I'm not even gonna remove the watermark.
Oh, there's so many lasagnas Oh my god, some would say this is a little too much lasagna.
Okay This is this might be a little too much lasagna.
Some would say that
There's one lasagna There's um There's two lasagna and then there is Three lasagna Oh my god, we have 10 lasagnas.
Oh my god lasagna for the whole House as in me Yeah Yay Thank you everybody for all the lasagnas I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait now I need to put more lasagna Oh my god.
There's so many lasagnas now.
No, I I don't need to put them on place anymore There's way too many lasagnas.
Like what am I gonna do with all these?
Uh, what am I gonna do with all these plates guys?
Like what am I?
Oh my god.
There's four This is four I can't tell there's six.
Oh, there's so many There's so many.
What am I gonna?
Guys, I think I I think I fucked up.
I think there's way too many
Oh, no, it's covering up the people now, oh no, there's a lot of lasagna
Oh No, oh no, what have I done?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Okay, there we go.
Me and my 10 lasagnas
Xero thank you for the magenta.
We did it I'm actually gonna order lasagna.
Wait, actually i'm gonna order lasagna right now Fuck it.
Today's my cheat day It makes my Turkey I feel like you've had several cheat days already.
No.
No, this is the last one.
This is a special occasion I'm gonna order lasagna right now and i'll post it.
I'll post a photo of it after the stream when I receive it How do I spell lasagna?
Oh, there's a Wait, how do I spell lasagna though?
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, this looks good.
Oh, all right guys.
Oh Okay, do we get oh, there's mozzarella sticks.
Okay guys um Oh my god, wait, okay guys All right.
Oh, they literally just oh my god.
Okay.
I'll get the the uh Oh, i'll get oh guys.
What's a what's a jalapeno?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I want this too.
Okay.
All right guys This is a lot of food What am I saying?
I'm garfield.
That's not enough What am I saying it's never enough
All right, i'm ordering All right Nice.
All right Guys, this are I don't think i'm role-playing anymore
Can't be stopped I don't think i'm role-playing anymore guys because No, no I'm going in too deep.
I'm what's it called when like an actor like gets too into the character What is that method acting it's getting to me guys i'm in too deep I'm in too deep everybody.
What do I do?
Become one with the Oh my god, i'm gonna jared leto this i'm gonna i'm gonna cheer about this and send people lasagna She's becoming
Oh no, oh no, we're losing her we're losing her to jared leto and garfield But is it truly losing me if i'm becoming if i'm becoming one with what I love the most
Is This is where your super chat goes to remember that This is your oshi
Stream uh audio.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Chat, did we just become feeders?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Oh my god, i'm so excited for my lasagna.
Oh, when's my lasagna gonna get here?
Wait, I hope this is a good place for lasagna Guys if it's not good lasagna i'm gonna be very sad like this was the whole point Oh my god, wait, I could have ordered lasagna at a better place No
No, this has to
be 50.
Wait, how many people order from this one?
You're right I should just buy more lasagna I should just but what you're right guys If I order two lasagnas, then i'll just have two lasagnas Like oh my god, you guys are right.
You guys Guys double the lasagna Double the food
Eight more you're right eight more to go guys eight more to go.
Um, man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I can't cancel They're already trying to make it guys
No Oh They're ready we we help Cancel order.
Oh my god.
Canceled ordered.
Okay Oh my god, we're finishing my order they're gonna No,
no, they said i'll charge me 36 dollars if I cancel No Guys, do I do it?
Do I do it?
Do I order two lasagna?
I'm just gonna order two lasagnas.
Don't fuck you.
I'm just I mean you guys literally paid for my lasagna.
I might as well.
I'm Well, this is where literally how can you guys be surprised it literally said I literally wrote um This this this fund the goal was to buy lasagna.
That's you guys enabled me.
That's not Yes, it's not it's not my fault I was only enabled by the system you guys you guys enabled me
You guys you guys knew what's gonna happen I literally wrote i'm gonna buy lasagna with this With these super chats and you still gave me.
Why are you still?
I was like, why would I need like 10 super chats for one lasagna?
You guys know you guys know where it was gonna go to it was gonna go to more than 10 more than one lasagna It was it was written in the fine print.
Oh my god.
This this this restaurant has like 2 000 reviews She did What have we done just remember jokey feel the need to yell up it's carving time you you've gone too deep into the whole Stop before you go Thank you for the super chat script, thank you.
Thank you.
We are we're not enabling anyone Thank you for the magenta soup.
Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Here is for lasagna three Thank you, thank you All right Bye.
All right.
I'm doing it.
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, i'm gonna do it.
Oh, yeah Oh my god, I can add oh I can add meatballs.
Oh my god Don't you already added mozzarella sticks on the other order?
No, but you don't understand I can add meatballs on this one.
This is different.
This is a different path.
This is a different pasta place guys It's a different lasagna place It doesn't count Oh my god, it doesn't count guys.
It doesn't count
I Like to think that That you're you're like a huge garfield fan and then you're like finally a vtuber that i'll actually enjoy I'm joining her membership right now I just like you're like finally, this is the content i've always wanted i'm gonna I'm just like out of all the streams.
This is the what this is the stream That pushed you over the edge to join the membership.
Like this was it.
This was what you've always wanted No, i'm catering to a new audience finally I am for the people My cheat day with my 10 lasagnas do I add meatballs i'm gonna do it i'm gonna add meatballs Nobody's gonna stop me you guys enabled I'm gonna add meatballs.
We're gonna see which one is the better lasagna.
I'm gonna do it All right request utensils.
All right, nice All right.
I have two lasagnas coming in.
I did Different place equals different meatballs.
Um, I don't think it was a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Um, welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome a seagull.
Thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you Ever since you came back i've been waiting for the perfect time to truly support you.
I don't think there's a better time than Thank you for the akasupa All i'm all i'm saying is that this is when you know you chose the right oshi It's soggy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just joined.
I have no fucking know what's going on But good luck finding a five dollar lasagna Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right guys I did it guys I got my lasagna.
I got two lasagna.
Don't worry guys.
I got two lasagnas, too I
Oh my god, I can't wait you guys enable you guys knew what was gonna happen You guys thought I was joking when I said I was gonna get lasagna.
Like why do you think I needed 10?
magenta supers Why you think you think there's no and there's no place in the world where one Where one lasagna would be that expensive you knew what was gonna happen You knew what was gonna happen
He's running through him he's running through the lasagna, oh my god
That's fun guys, all right guys, I hope you guys
All right, let's let's go back to dad real quick, let's go back to dad
Let's go back.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god, wait Wait, I made a mistake.
All right Let me put this here.
Okay Let me put all of this here real quick guys me and my me and my Okay All right.
There we go Let's put this all the way here.
So it works And then i'll put the plate right here.
All right Anyway, um That's fun.
I had a great time with you guys.
I had a great time with uh What do you mean what do you mean he brought me he brought me the 10 lasagnas chat
I guys I hope you guys this is a really quick stream.
Um But I hope this is a memorable stream for all of you guys um Regarding lasagna updates gonna take an hour to get here because I don't know you guys know this but lasagna actually takes a very long Time to make i'm like i'm
No, don't leave us don't leave I don't we don't know when you'll ever come back.
Don't feel Don't feel no
But um, I had a great time dragons, I Was it was fun shit posting with you guys on it Which was fun shit posting with you guys again And I hope you guys enjoyed this special halloween stream.
I know it could have been longer but like I want my lasagna
I want to relax a little bit before I eat my lasagna my two My two lasagnas
But I hope you guys have a great halloween.
I hope you guys enjoy Uh today's stream and as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing If you stayed up for me head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll give you guys a lasagna update When I get it, which is in an hour because it take a while to they take a while to make Hey guys, i'll see you guys later.
Everybody.
Bye.
Bye Bye Oh, yeah shit.
Fuck.
Um, I forgot to show you.
Okay guys, here are the people that made Oh, sorry Sorry, not bye-bye yet.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Sorry guys.
I almost forgot the most important thing credits
Okay, hold hold hold This guy okay.
Wait, I need All right.
Give me a sec guys guys guys before you go before you go All right Credits.
Oh my god.
Okay This guy Made the chat check him out Wait, wait, can my mod like link it on twitter or link it on twitter link it in my chat guys I'm a little mess right now garfield is not meant to do work stuff guys garfield Bill was not meant to make don't don't feel please don't sue me james davis don't feel this
is Joke field i'm a parody i'm a parody Joke field is not meant to
To do work, this is goblin was the one that created, um, my cat suit, um
Uh halloween music the halloween remix was done by A throw i'm, sorry.
I didn't make fancy icons.
I didn't have time.
I got back from my dance I should have made it before my dance lessons, but like I'm dog field.
I have an excuse i'm literally dog field, right?
I I excuse me.
I have an excuse right now like Don't look at me like that.
I I literally have an excuse right now for this Um
All right, this is who made the remix of um the remix of the halloween intro, um Ramen, oh my gosh, please tell me you linked your twitter.
Oh, thank god you did No, wait, no, that's your steam.
What's your twitter?
Wait, that's your steam.
Why did he have you?
Oh my god.
What's your twitter?
I don't remember your twitter Oh my god, tell me you linked your twitter on your twitch.
Oh my god.
Oh My dude, oh there oh wait, there's twitter I found his twitter.
It's literally the same username.
Okay.
All right all right The animation i'll show you guys the animation again, too guys.
All right.
Let me show you guys I really love the animation.
It's so cute.
Let me show you guys
That's how you guys got here Oh shit, oh my god double goons.
Oh my god Oh my god, oh my god now I have two of you guys here i'm breaking in There's two there's two odies I mean Anyway, that's the animation the mod the the dragoon reskins were done by Um, oh my gosh, what's your twitter?
Oh, there it is.
No, that's your region I'm a mess right now.
I'm joke field Joke field is less professional than regular doki Joke field is so much less professional You don't understand I have an excuse I have an excuse and then um These are the mod 3d modelers who did the reskin of the the house for the Designing the halloween at dragoons outfit.
All right.
Anyway guys, please check all these people out they did Um, they did an amazing job with everything um I had this plan out for like I think like a month and a half I think Oh, wait, wait guys.
Wait, wait a minute.
I'm so stupid.
How could I?
How could I forget something so important?
I forgot.
Yeah How could I forget something so important when it comes to?
Credits, there we go There we go.
Good old comic Now this is immersion Now we're immersed there we go
Hey guys, um, check them out they did a lot to make this possible to make my My dumb stream idea reality.
It's not dumb.
You know what?
This isn't dumb This is passion right there this is It's not dumb it's called passion Anyway anyway It's peak exactly.
Hey guys.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye
Secret ending wait, wait, wait guys
Dad i'm hungry dad
Only true gamers will remember that